hello world Shawn grooms here with free
code camp and in this video I will be
giving you three tips on how to learn
discrete mathematics the first tip is to
stay calm
people often hear the word mathematics
and panic and when you panic you stop
listening and if you stop listening you
can't learn the material so if you
simply stay calm
then you will be able to learn the
material better you aren't being graded
on the subject so there's no need to
panic the second is to rewind you can
rewind the videos at any time and when I
learn discrete mathematics I didn't have
this opportunity so in theory you should
be able to learn the material much
faster than I was ever able to so I
strongly encourage rewinding videos
finally explain once you think you
understand the material of the videos
you can try to explain the material out
loud either to yourself or to a friend
if no one's around or you feel weird
talking to yourself then you can try to
explain it to rubber ducky there is a
concept in programming called rubber
duck debugging which is where
programmers go through their code line
by line trying to identify bugs in their
code by explaining it to rubber duckie
so similarly if you go through the
material of the videos subject by
subject you will soon be able to
identify any gaps in your understanding
of the material
in this video I'll be explaining what
discrete mathematics is and why it's
important for the field of computer
science and programming discrete
mathematics is a branch of mathematics
that deals with discrete or finite sets
of elements rather than continuous or
infinite sets of elements imagine trying
to run a program that requires an
infinite number of executions to
complete attacks it's obvious to say
that the program would run forever and
the task would never be completed
because there an infinite number of
executions in order to avoid this
problem we approximate the continuous
sets with discrete sets now you may be
thinking I never use math that involves
infinite sets but I promise that you do
the simplest example is with a circle a
circle by definition is an infinite
number of points equidistant from a
fixed point and the problem with this is
that if we try to write a program that
prints out all of these points it will
run forever because they're an infinite
number of points and therefore an
infinite number of executions so this is
physically impossible that's why if we
zoom in here you can see that the when
you come down to here there are all
these points but in reality we should
have even more points between these
points and then if we zoom in on those
we'll have more points between those
points and we can never complete the
task now we've all seen circles on
computers so what's going on how is this
possible we just established that it's
impossible well the answer is that
they're approximations for example
consider regular polygons regular
polygons like a triangle or a square or
a Pentagon those don't really look like
circles but if you keep increasing the
number of vertices eventually you'll
start getting hexagons octagons
dodecagon x' hexa decagons
i cosas Gon's you can see that these
regular polygons the more or more you
keep increasing the number of vertices
which the vertices are equidistant from
a fixed point they will eventually
approximate a circle eventually they
will be indistinguishable to the naked
eye and will look identical to a circle
and in this video I'll be explaining
what sets are a set is a collection of
distinct objects called elements or
members an element is essentially
anything you want it to be and for
example elements could be numbers
letters variables more sets or nothing
at all
sets are usually denoted by capital
letters such as capital a capital B C E
or F and we say that the set contains
elements for example we could say that
the set a equals the set containing the
element 5 or we can say that 5 is an
element of a now I will be introducing a
lot of symbols like this this just means
is an element of and it'll save us a lot
of time in future videos and I don't
have to write out is an element of each
time so that will come in handy so what
does a set actually look like well there
are two common types of notation for
sets and the one I'm introducing in this
video is roster notation then it looks
like this is just curly braces with
elements inside separated by commas
which is very similar to JavaScript the
only difference being that in math we
use curly braces and in JavaScript we
use square break bracket so now let's
just walk through these so the set a
equals the set containing the element
that's how you would read this the set D
equals the set containing elements 2 3 &
4 the set C equals the set containing
elements D F and G now D F and G they're
not they don't have to be variables
there they're either variables or they
can be characters it just depends on the
context the set E contains no elements
in this case which has an impact that
you'll see in future videos and finally
the set F equals the set containing
elements a B and C in this case our
elements are sets so we would read this
as F equals the set containing the set
containing the element 5 the set
containing elements 2 3 & 4 and the set
containing d FG
so in the next video I'll be going over
a different form of set notation in
addition to introducing you to some
common sets and this will set us up
eventually my goal is to bring us up to
being able to define and understand
algorithms and this is where we have to
begin
in this video I'll be introducing
interval notation and talk about some
common sets this will lay the foundation
for the next video on set builder
notation the beauty of interval notation
is that allows us to efficiently
describe all numbers between two values
suppose we wanted to say that the
variable X is between 0 & 1 well we can
do just that we could say that X is an
element of 0 the interval 0 or 1 or
which is really saying X is greater than
0 and X is less than 1 likewise if we
wanted to say that X is greater than or
equal to 0 and X is less than 1 then we
have to switch this to a square bracket
all we're doing is we are now including
the number 0 in the interval also we can
include 0 and we can also include 1 in
the interval by using square brackets on
both sides so it's greater than or equal
to and less than they go to and now I'll
talk about some common sets the first
one being the null set which is the same
thing as the empty set which is just
there are no elements contained within
the set and this will come in handy in
the future the funny end here is the
natural numbers which is the set
containing elements 1 2 3 and then these
3 dots here are called an ellipsis which
tells us that the pattern continues so n
is the set containing 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 all
the way up to infinity this funny end
with a 0 is the natural numbers however
it includes the value 0 within the set
so it's 0 1 2 and then the ellipsis
tells us all the way to infinity in an
integer fashion 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 and
finally we have all of the integers
positive and negative and non-negative
which is 0 negative 1 negative 2 all the
way down to negative infinity and 0 1 2
3 4 all the way up to infinity
in this video I'll be introducing the
rational numbers and set builder
notation the rational numbers are
defined as a ratio of two integers and
examples include the integers themselves
terminating decimals and repeating
decimals so let's start with repeating
decimals if we let 10x equal nine point
nine nine nine repeating then if we
divide by both sides by 10 then x equals
zero point nine nine nine repeating and
if we subtract X from 10x we have 9x
equals nine and then divide both sides
by nine we have x equals one and then if
we multiply by ten both sides by 10 we
have 10x equals 10 so now we have 10x
equals 10 but 10x also equals nine point
nine nine and repeating so we have now
and these are in fact true nine point
nine nine repeating equals ten so we
think we can now express 10x as an
integer which is a rational number we
can put 10 divided by one which is a
ratio so another problem we have is
terminating decimals if we have two
point seven eight equal to Y then we can
just easily say 278 divided by 100
equals y as well these are two integers
and it's a another rational number so a
convenient way to define these is
denoted with a Q and this is called set
builder notation we have the Q equals
the set containing elements a divided by
B such that a and B are elements of the
integers when the only condition that B
cannot equal zero if you divide by zero
its its undefined it doesn't mean
anything so if you're interested in that
I recommend googling it I think it's
interesting
in this video I'll be giving an example
of a non rational number if the square
root of two were a rational number then
by definition it must be expressed as
the ratio of two integers if we then
square both sides we have two equals a
squared divided by B squared if we
multiply both sides by B squared we have
two B squared equals a squared and from
this we know that a squared is even a
squared is even because we have two
times some integer which is B squared
since a squared is even we know that a
is even because a squared equals two
times some integer the integer I chose
was 2k squared that means that a times a
can be expressed as 2 K times 2k which
is to say that a equals 2k I can now
substitute 2 times 2k squared for a
squared and that leaves us with B
squared equals 2k squared
once these twos cancel out now this also
means that B squared is even because B
squared equals 2 times some integer
which is to say that B is also even
following this same logic now if we go
back to our original premise the square
root of 2 equals a divided by B where a
divided by B is an irreducible fraction
but since a is an even number and B is
also an even number we can express these
numbers as 2 K + 2 L but these twos here
will reduce meaning that we'll have the
square root of 2 equals K divided by L
but since this reduced since this is no
longer explicitly represented as a
divided by B and it reduced to K divided
by L we know that we do not have a
rational number now there's a more
specific way to define these numbers or
classify these numbers but we need set
operators in the next video
in this video I'll be defining four
binary operators for sets I've defined
two sets a and B to help give some
examples so the first is a union B which
equals a set containing elements P such
that P is an element of a or P is an
element of B the next is the
intersection a intersection B equals the
set containing elements P such that P is
an element of a and P is an element of B
the next is the set difference of a and
B which equals the set containing P or
elements P such that P is an element of
a and P is not an element of B and
finally we have the symmetric difference
which is going to be very helpful when
you actually complete the symmetric
difference algorithm challenge so the
symmetric difference of a and B equals
the set difference of a and B Union with
the set difference of B and a and
finally I will define the irrational
numbers which I hinted to at the end of
last video so the irrational numbers are
simply the real number real numbers
minus the rational numbers and that
equals the irrational numbers
in this video I will be using Venn
diagrams to give a graphical
representation of the set operators we
learned in the previous video so if you
recall the definition of a union B you
know that a union B equals the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of a or X is an element of B so
if we let this circle represent the set
a and we let this circle represent the
set B then that means that X can land
anywhere in any of these circles which
is why this red the entire region is
shaded red we're saying that this red
region represents all possible values of
X and if we recall the definition of a
of a intersection B that equals the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of a and X is an element of B
which is why the overlap where a B
overlap is is shaded red we're saying
all possible values of X are this red
region now the set difference of a and B
equals the set containing elements X
such that X is an element of a and X is
also not an element of B which is why
it's just this region here none of the
elements are within B the set difference
of B and a is the set containing
elements X such that X is an element of
B and X is not an element of a and
finally the symmetric difference of a
and B I defined as the union of a minus
B and B minus a so we take this region
in this region and we take the union of
it which is why this is the resulting
region there's no overlap between the
two now this is a really good way to
familiarize yourself with the concept of
set operators however don't rely on it
you should really focus on the
definitions as it will help you out in
the long term
in this video I'll be introducing the
concept of subsets and supersets the
dots on the board here represent
elements of a set the lines represent
the sets themselves these lines have
been labeled B a and u we can say that B
is a subset of a because B contains
because all elements of B are elements
of a we can also say that B is a proper
subset of a because all elements of B
are elements of a and there are elements
of a that are not within the set B we
can also say that the set a is a
superset of the set B because a contains
all of the elements of B and being even
more specific we can say that a is a
proper superset of B because a contains
all elements of B and there are elements
of a that are not elements of B what we
cannot say is that U is a proper subset
of a although the circle here is bigger
than a like it just takes up more space
it doesn't contain any more elements so
all the elements so u contains all
elements of a however u does not contain
any extra elements so U is a subset of a
and a is actually a subset of U U is a
superset of a and a is also a superset
of U so these sets a and u in this case
are actually equal
in this video I'll be introducing the
concept of the universal set and
compliments so I want to begin by
talking about the universal set which is
commonly referred to as the universe now
the reason I used this fancy looking you
here is that I was defining the universe
which is to say the maximum boundaries
of my set my biggest set everything
outside of this blue circle here doesn't
exist I mean it in terms of the sets
nothing exists I don't even exist
computers are just you don't exist but
everything within it does so that's a
very important key now if I don't define
this if I don't define my Universal set
then we just assume it to be the real
numbers so if I just erase this then you
know this will just be the real numbers
which is we've talked about in previous
videos so the other thing I want to talk
about is complements so if I say if I'm
looking for the complement of B and I'll
put a more formal definition of if I'm
looking for the complement of B then it
is everything that is not within B so
all the elements not within B are gonna
be part of the conflict complement so in
this case it would look like this if I
just highlighted everything it would be
everything within the universe still and
then so that is the complement of B it's
all the elements that are not in B so
that's that's quite a bit of quite a bit
I mean there you go one two three so
since this is the real numbers these
little dots here would represent all the
numbers all every single value rational
irrational that are not within B so if
this is 1 in 2 or better yet how about
this this is the
rational numbers and these are the
integers so these would be everything
outside of this would be the irrational
numbers and the non integer values
in this video I'll be giving examples
for subsets and supersets so if you look
at this blue line here this represents
our Universal set we've defined it to be
the integers from 1 to 11 that's 1 2 3 4
all the way up to 11
don't let it concern you that there are
elements outside of our universe that
just means that they are I mean that
just means they're not in the universe
that we have in question right now so
it's no different than having stars
outside of your galaxy you're not
concerned by that it's just a matter of
that so if you look at this green line
what what set would that be well it can
say its elements 3 beta and gamma
so does B be contains 3 beta and gamma
so this would be the set B likewise this
set here it contains elements 3 1 and X
well a contains 3 1 and X so this is the
set hey and finally this set contains
elements 1 & 3 this set contains
elements 1 & 3 so this is the set C now
what can be said about these sets well
we have we can say that C is a subset of
the universe because all elements of C
are elements of the universe furthermore
we can say that the set B is not a
subset of the universe because there are
elements of B that are not within the
universe also we can say that the
universe is not a subset that a superset
of a because there's elements of a that
are not within are not contained by the
universe and finally we can say that the
universe is a proper superset of C
because the universe contains all
elements of C except Al and there are
elements within the universe that are
not within the set C so if we wanted to
be more specific we could actually say
that C is a proper subset of the
universe
in this video I'll be going over
examples of compliments so in this video
I've defined the universe to be the
integers 1 through 5 and it's denoted
graphically by this blue line and if we
recall the definition of the compliments
whether or with regards to a we have a
compliment equals the set containing
elements X such that X is an element of
the universe and X is not an element of
a so in that case we can look at all the
integers 1 through 5 and if it contains
any element from a we throw it out so in
this case if we look at the integer 1 we
know that that's not going to be there
because that's an a if we look at the
integer 2 that'll be in our set we look
at the integer 3 that won't be in our
set because that's also an egg and then
4 and 5 are within the universe and
they're not with a name next we have B
complement well we know that 1 2 4 & 5
are within the universe and they're not
within B and lastly we have C complement
2 4 and 5 are within the universe and
they're not within C because we had to
exclude 1 & 3
I want to begin this video by reviewing
our definitions of the union and
intersection after that I'll be
introducing two algebraic laws for sets
so the definition of a union B equals
set containing elements X such that X is
an element of a or X is an element of B
also a intersection B is defined as the
set containing elements X such that X is
an element of a and X is an element of B
so when I introduce the in impotant slaw
it should be clear that a union a equals
a because a union a is defined as the
set containing elements X such that X is
an element a or X is an element of a
which should yield or you should see why
that equals the set a also a
intersection a equals the set containing
elements X such that X is an element of
a and X is an element of a which it
should also be clear why that is to set
a next we have our identity laws so
identity laws are laws where we have a
given set and we're performing an
operation on that set with a given
element these elements are the identity
elements so for this case we have the
null set and the universal set our
identity elements so a union null set
equals a and by definition that means
that a union null set equals the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of a or X is an element of the
null set but since we know that the null
set is empty we can't possibly have any
elements in there so it's really saying
that a union of null set is equal to the
set containing elements X such that X is
an element of a or more simply it equals
a
I want to begin this video by reviewing
the definition of complements so the
definition of a complement of a set for
the for instance the complement of a
equals the set containing elements X
such that X is not an element of a I'll
now be going over to new algebraic laws
for sets the first are the law of
complements the law of complements
states that if we take the union of a
set and its complement it equals the
universe or if you take the complement
of the null set it equals the universe
furthermore the intersection of a set
and its complement is the null set and
that should be clear because if you have
the set a and you are intersecting it
with everything that is not inside a
there's a clearly not going to be any
overlap so you're gonna have an empty
set the next one is the law of evolution
so involution states that if we have a
state here let's cut we'll call it state
zero and we feed that state to a
function in this case we're gonna feed
it to the complement function then when
I gets to state one if we again feed it
through the exact same function the
complement function it will result in
state zero again in this case if we fed
state a if we fed set a through this
cyclical function here then we would
have a feed it through a complement we
get a complement feed it back through
the function we get a complement
complement which equals a and then we
could have a complement couple of a
complement which would be a complement
and then you get the idea it's cyclical
in this video I'm introducing two more
algebraic laws for sets associativity
and commutativity associativity is
essentially just saying that we can
regroup the sets that we are talking
about so a intersection b intersection c
that is a intersecting with the set b
intersection c is equal to the set a
intersection b intersection c and if you
look at the definitions of intersection
you can actually go through and figure
out why this is and i'm pretty sure
you'll be able to do that based on the
videos that you've already watched and
the same is true for the union community
is essentially just saying that we can
switch which side our sets are relative
to the operations so a intersection B is
the same thing as B intersection a and
the same thing is a union B is equal to
B Union a so if we look at the actual
definition we have a intersection B is
defined as the set containing elements X
such that X is an element of a and X is
an element of B and that's going to
equal the set containing elements X such
that X is an element of B and X is an
element of a so if you just look at
these the conditions for these for the
set builder notation here it's
essentially just a argument of grammar
at this point so basic English will tell
you that you can just switch which side
that you have these 1
in this video I'll be introducing
another algebraic law of sets the
distributive law the distributive law is
simply saying that the set and operation
will be distributed over another set in
operation for instance a intersection B
Union C equals a or section B Union a
intersection C so I thought it might be
helpful to use Venn diagrams for the
conceptual idea of this and then I'll do
a separate video on the actual
definition so if we look at a here and
we separate a and then we decide to
separate B Union C then when we actually
go to find the union or the intersection
of these two regions it's easy to see
that it is this region so hopefully for
the purposes of equality this region
here will match this region here so
let's get right to it we have a
intersection B so we have to set a and
the set B so that means that a
intersection B is going to be this
region here and we have to also find a
intersection C so that's this region and
if we take the union of those two
regions then we're left with all of this
jazz so it looks like they are in fact
equal but to be more rigorous we'll
revisit the actual definition of the
intersection in the unions in the next
video
in my previous video on subsets and
supersets I stated that to show quality
you have to prove that each side of an
equation are subsets of each other so to
prove the distributive law we're gonna
have this video we're gonna have the
next video in this video I'm gonna be
showing that a is a a intersection B you
see is a subset of a intersection B
Union a intersection C so let's start
the proof suppose that X is an element
of a intersection B you see then X is an
element of a and X is an element of B
Union C by definition of the
intersection so we still know that X is
an element of a and by definition we
know that X is an element of B or X is
an element of C from this we can deduce
that X is an X is an element of a and X
is an element of B or X is an element of
a and X is element of C now by
definition we can put this or rewrite
this as X is an element of a
intersection B or X is an element of a
intersection C and finally we can deduce
that X is an element of a intersection B
Union a intersection C
so there you have it we've shown that
since X is an element of a intersection
B Union C and X is an element of a
intersection B Union a intersection C X
is in both of these and therefore a
intersection B Union C is in fact a
subset of a intersection B Union a
intersection C
in this video I have the proof of the
second case for the distributive law in
this case we're showing that a
intersection B Union a intersection C is
a subset of a intersection B Union C so
let's start by saying that suppose that
X is an element of a intersection B
Union a intersection C then we know that
X is an element of a intersection B or X
is an element of a intersection C and we
know this because of the definition of
the Union from here we can then state
that X is an element of a and X is an
element of B or X is an element of a and
X is an element of C from that we can
deduce that X is an element of a and X
is an element of B or X is an element of
C and here we we sort of factored out
the X as an element of a and and then
regrouped X is element of B or X is an
element of C and from here we can by
definition write exosome a and X is an
element of B Union C which finally we
can state X is an element of a
intersection B Union C which is what we
wanted to show so they have we've proved
that X is an element of both of these
and therefore this is a subset of dis
and we've shown that both sides of the
equation are subsets of each other and
therefore the distributive law is in
fact true it's proven
in this video I'll be going over an
example of the distributive law so if
you look at a intersection B Union C
that is supposed to equal a intersection
B Union a intersection C so if we can if
we decompose this equation and look at
let's start with a intersection B then
that equals singleton 3 based off from
these predetermined sets and then if we
look at a intersection C that equals the
set 1 3 so the union of these two is
going to be the set containing elements
1 & 3 now if we look at B Union C that
equals the set containing elements 1 3
beta and gamma and if we take the
intersection of that set with a we're
left with this set containing elements 1
& 3 which is good because now we've
shown that this that now if we look at a
union B intersection C that's supposed
to equal a B intersection a union C so
for you analyze B intersection C that
equals singleton 3 and then a you need
be right here equals 1 3 X beta gamma in
a union C equals the set containing
elements 1 3 and X so when we take the
intersection of these two sets
we're left with the set containing
elements 1 3 and X and when we take the
union of B intersection C with a we're
left with the second taining elements 1
3 and X which is exactly what we wanted
so yeah we've shown that these are in
fact true
in this video I'll be introducing the
very last algebraic law of sets known as
de Morgan's law de Morgan's law was
founded by Augustus de Morgan and it
states that the complement of a union is
the intersection of the complements or
it says that the complement of the
intersection is a union of the
complements so we're gonna prove that
the complement of the union of a and B
is is in fact equal to the complement of
a intersected with the complement of B
so to do this we have to show that the
complement of a UV B is a subset of a
complement intersection B complement and
vice-versa so let's get started
suppose that X is an element of a union
B complement if that's the case then by
definition X is not an element of a
union B and if X is not an element of a
union B that is if X is not an element
of the region a union B which is the red
here then surely X is not an element of
a and X is not an element of B and if
that's the case then by definition X is
not an element of a complement and X is
not an element of B complement therefore
X is not an element of a complement
intersection B complement so if we go to
the other side here we start by saying
let's let's suppose that X is an element
of a complement intersection B
complement then by definition X is an
element of a complement and X is element
of B complement by definition of the
complements X is not an element of a and
X is not an element of B and with the
same logic X is not an element of a
union B because X is not an element of
this region and X is not an element of
this region so surely it's not an
element of the two regions combined and
by definition of complements X is an
element of a union B complement
in this video in this video I'll be
giving examples of de Morgan's law the
Morgan's law states that the complement
of the intersection equals the union of
the complements and that the complement
of the Union equals the intersection of
the complements so if we check out these
new that this new Universal set here it
is equal to the second taining integers
such that X is greater than equal to
zero and X is less than or equal to five
or more simply the universe equals the
set containing integers from zero to
five so if we decompose our first
equation a intersection B equals
singleton three the complement of a
intersection B is going to be integers
from zero to five excluding a
intersection B so zero one two four and
five now the complement of a is equal to
two two zero two four and five because a
contains the integers 1 & 3 so those are
excluded and B complement is going to be
equal to 0 1 2 4 5 because B contains 3
so it's excluded so the intersection are
the Union rather of a complement and B
complement equals 0 1 2 4 & 5 which is
in fact equal to the complement of a
intersection B which is what we want so
the next equation we have a union B and
that's equal to 1 3 X beta gamma
now the complement of that is equal to 0
2 4 5 because we've excluded everything
from a union B and now if we look at a
complement intersection B complement we
also have the set containing elements 0
2 4 5 so which is exactly what we wanted
so now we know that these two are equal
so there you have it both of our
equations worked out and we can happily
use demorgan's law
in this video I'll be explaining what
logic is and why we need it I want to
begin with in excerpt from the book of
proof by Richard hammock this is a free
text book and it's excellent you can
find it online and it covers all
foundational mathematics to include
discrete mathematics and I cannot
recommend it enough
so the excerpt is logic is a systematic
way of thinking that allows us to deduce
new information from old information and
to parse the meaning of sentences so
what this is saying is that essentially
with without logic we wouldn't be able
to deduce or move from point A to point
B and or make claims from point A to
point B in a hundred percent affirmative
no-questions-asked
way and so that so that's very important
for mathematics if you couldn't do that
in mathematics then it would all fall
apart either there would be no certainty
there would be no foundation no argument
for us to stand on and we would just be
a bunch of people throwing numbers
abouting making guesses essentially so
it's very very important the parsing the
other part of the quote to parse the
meaning of sentences won't make sense
until later videos when we actually do
that so just bear with me on that one so
why should you care about programmers so
well programmers use algorithms while
programmers write code first of all code
uses algorithms algorithms is
essentially just math and mathematics
requires logic so it's that simple
in this video I'll be introducing the
notion of a proposition a proposition is
simply a declarative statement with a
verifiable truth value they are usually
denoted by lowercase letters so if we
have this lowercase P equals rain falls
from the sky and that's a true statement
rain does fall from the sky but it could
have been a false statement like q q
equals God is a country in Asia Ghana's
not a country in Asia or Ghana is a
country in Africa so this is a false
proposition or a false statement are
what are you doing there's no truth
value that can be assigned to that it's
just it's just a question it's
considered an open statement s equals
wash the laundry again this is an open
statement it has no truth value to it
it's a command v equals 4 plus 89 that
again that that that does actually have
a truth value to it but it's again it's
a false state because 5 does not equal 4
plus 89 7 equals alpha I don't know if
it does I mean I'm not I don't know what
alpha is so this is an open statement we
can't verify the truth of this 3 equals
5 divided by 0 this is a proposition
this is how this has a truth value
because 3 does not equal 5 divided by 0
that's five divided by zero is undefined
and then 99 times 1/3 equals 33 so this
does have a verify a verifiable truth
value and it's true
in this video I'll be introducing the
concept of composite propositions just
like regular propositions composite
propositions are declarative statements
with a verifiable truth value composite
propositions are made up of sub
propositions and in this video we're
going to talk about the conjunction and
the disjunction so the first one i want
to introduce is the conjunction that is
p and cute that's how you would read
this P and Q and so this composite
proposition here is rain falls from the
sky and Ghana is a country in Asia so
the two sub propositions in this would
be P P and Q and this has a verifiable
truth value because rain falls from the
sky because that is a true statement but
the statement q Ghana is a country in
Asia is false we have P and Q we have
true and false which means that it's
false one of them is false and we'll
talk about this more when we get into
truth tables the next is the disjunction
P or Q that's read as or rain falls from
the sky or Ghana is a country in Asia so
again we have true or false this time so
only one of these need to be true in
order for everything to be true and
therefore P or Q is a true statement
in this video I'll be introducing truth
tables truth tables are the easiest way
to visualize why something is true or
false and they're really convenient when
we start getting up into conjunctions
and disjunctions so if you remember P
and Q P is defined as rain falls from
the sky and Q is Ghana is a country in
Asia then P or Q or both P and Q have
two possible values true or false their
primitive propositions so we just put
them in a table true and false and then
true or false
but I circled these because I know that
P is true and I know that Q is false but
when I analyze a conjunction or
disjunction I have to add two more rows
to the truth table and that's because if
you like if you imagine this as starting
on a path here you can choose to go
either true or false when it's say I
took true when I get to the end of that
path I can then choose true or false
again so I'm stuck with four different
possibilities here the first one being
true true true false and then false true
and then false false so when I actually
go to my table here I have true true
true false and yet and then when I stick
in my conjunction I have true and true
equals true true and false equals false
true false and true equals false and
then false and false equals false P or Q
true or true equals true true or false
equals true false or true equals true
and false or false equals false and
these are by the definitions of the
conjunction and the disjunction that's
why that's why these values take on true
or false
in this video I'll introduce our first
two algebraic laws of logic components
and identities these are the same laws
we saw on set theory if you recall it
impotant is when you can take a
proposition and apply a binary operator
to that proposition over and over and
will never change the value of the
original proposition for instance P is
the logical equivalent that's what these
mean the logical equivalent of P or P
which is the logical equivalent of P and
P and if you recall the definition of
the disjunction and the conjunction you
should be able to figure out why this
occurs now the identity law states that
if we take a proposition and we have a
conjunction with true a truth value in a
true value then it will always yield
that original proposition likewise if we
have a disjunction with a proposition
and false it will always yield the
original proposition that's why we have
P is the logical equivalent of P or
false which is the illogical equivalent
of P and true and finally we have true
and false the identities of true and
false so if you have the disjunction of
true with any proposition then you will
always yield a true value and if you
have a conjunction with any proposition
and false it will always yield the false
value
in this video I'll be introducing two
more algebraic laws of logic the law of
complements in the law of involution we
start by examining our permanent
proposition P we know that P either is
true or false
if we look at the negation of P which is
read as not P then we know that P is
false and true because not P is defined
as when P is true not P is false and
when P is false not P is true so the law
of involution tells us that if we have a
proposition and we feed it through a
function twice we'll end up in the same
spot
so if we have proposition P starting at
state 0 feed it through a function the
negation function it'll bring us a state
1 as not P if we feed not P through the
function it will bring us back to state
zero which is P or known as not not P so
P is logically equivalent to not not P
that's what involution tells us we then
analyze the law of complements which
tells us that the disjunction of p and
its negation not P will be the logical
equivalent of the true value so it is a
it is known as a tautology it is always
true and that's the corresponding truth
table here it also tells us that a
proposition and the conjunction of its
negation is always false which is known
as a fallacy so you can go through this
truth table and you'll see that we have
a tautology fallacy tautology tautology
fallacy and fallacy
in this video I'll be introducing
another algebraic law of logic
commutative law so we start by looking
at all possible cases of P and Q we know
that based on the path problem that we
did when I first introduced truth tables
we know that there's four possible cases
for both the disjunction and the
conjunction of P and Q so if we analyze
this we know that true and true or the
disjunction of P and Q is going to yield
true and also this is going to be true
and false yields true false and true
yields true and false and false is true
so all we're doing for the commutative
law is switching the order of Q and P on
the operation so instead of having P or
Q we have Q or P so in fact we do have
true true true false so we've shown that
both P or Q and Q or P are logically
equivalent for the conjunction of P and
Q by definition we know that true and
true is get a yield true true and false
yields false false and true yields false
and false and false yield yields false
so when we commute P and Q and we have Q
and P it's not surprising that we get
the exact same answer which is good
because now we've shown that P and Q is
logically equivalent to Q and P
in this video I'll be introducing the
associative law and the distributive law
for logic now previously we've only
dealt with two primitive propositions so
that's why we've only ever had four
possible outcomes in our true or false
path now we're going to take this a step
further and we're gonna have eight
propositions or eight possible outcomes
for our true or false path because we're
dealing with three propositions P Q and
R so there's not much to be said about
the associative law or the shriveled law
and unfortunately I can't fit the truth
table to prove these on my whiteboard
it's it and it gets really messy so I'm
gonna have them at the end of the video
and go through them make sure you
understand them and if you don't go back
and review the concepts of truth tables
you
in this video I'll be introducing our
last algebraic law of logic de Morgan's
law de Morgan's law states that the
negation of the conjunction is the
logical equivalent of the disjunction of
the negations and also that the negation
of the disjunction is the logical
equivalent of the conjunction of the
negations so if we look at our truth
table i've decomposed our propositions
here so that we have P naught P Q naught
Q and I have it all out on the board so
that I can just simply look at naught P
and Q which is our first law and see
that it is in fact equivalent to not P
or not Q so these two columns are equal
so we can definitively say that these
are logical equivalence also not P or Q
is the is in fact not P and not Q based
on our truth table it's 100% certain
this is logic and there's a no argument
against it
in this video I'll be introducing the
notion of conditional statements a
conditional statement contains a
hypothesis and a conclusion these are
more formally known as an antecedent and
a consequent so all this is saying is
that when we look at these the actual
conditional this is the hypothesis and
this is a conclusion so P implies this
is read as P implies Q and also as if P
then Q so P implies Q is only false when
a hypothesis leads to a false conclusion
or a antecedent leads to leads to a
false consequence so that's why we have
if we have true implies true that leads
to a true statement and if we have true
implies false that leads to a false
statement these other three the converse
inverse and contrapositive are
essentially they're just common
implications that we run into or common
conditional statements that we run into
and the converse is simply Q implies P
inverse is not P implies not Q and not Q
implies not P is lot which is
contrapositive is logically equivalent
to the original conditional statement
in this video I'll be introducing the
universal and existential quantifiers
but first I have to introduce the
propositional function the propositional
function denoted P of X takes on a value
of true or false but it takes on a value
of true or false for everything that you
feed to it so in this case with the
universal quantifier this is read as for
every you would say for every X that is
an element of the universe P of X is
either true or false for every X the
shorthand for this is for every X P of X
you could also say there exists that's
the existential quantifier there exist
is just stating that there is at least
one so if we say there exists you know
there exists an X that is an element of
the universe we're saying there is at
least one X at least one X that is an
element a universe such that P of X is
true or false and you can again use the
shorthand there exists an X P of X so
when we look at these examples for every
X that is an element of the naturals X
plus 3 is greater than 4 so that is a
that is a false statement
because the first value of the natural
numbers is 1 so X plus 3 is 4 which is
not greater than 4 also for every X is
an element of the real numbers X plus 3
is greater than 4 that is also false I
can think of
well there are infinitely many numbers
that are not true for this and then in
this case I said there does not exist in
X that is now under the naturals such
that X plus 3 is greater than 4 and that
is also a false statement because if I
let X equal to that 2 is a natural
number and 2 plus 3 is greater than 4 so
this is a false statement
there are just an element of the real
numbers such that X plus 3 is greater
than 4 that is a true statement because
any number greater than 1 is going to
yield a true statement in this case
in this video I'm going to be going over
some examples of tautologies tautologies
are simply propositions that are always
true this first one is the law of
excluded middle which is P or not P so
for here we have P or not P some true or
false true or false false or true or
false or true which yields nothing but a
true column next we have the law of
contradiction so if you ignore this
negation here in this column of trues
here we have P and not P so true and
false seals false true and false false
false and true false and true allyou
false now when we actually apply this
negation to the false column here that
yields a column of truth so the law of
contradiction is a tautology
and finally we have modus tollens modus
tollens is P implies Q and not Q implies
not P so let's break this now P implies
Q P implies Q is only ever negative when
the hypothesis predicts true and the
conclusion is false so if we have true
implies true here is going to be true
true implies false that's false false
implies true is going to be true false
implies false that's also false I mean
that's also true we then take this
column and take the conjunction with not
Q so true and not false is going to
yield false false and true is going to
yield false again false and true is
going to yield false and true and true
is going to yield true so finally we
take this column here and that is our we
apply not P so this column implies not P
so false implying not P is going to be
true false implying false is going to be
true false implying true is also true
and true implying true is also true so
there you have we have this whole column
here for modus tollens and that is
therefore a tautology
there's nothing special about these
tautologies these are just examples of
tautologies